now there are different kinds of
fractions different kinds of fractions
the different ways to write them now
we're going to have a whole series of
words ideas here which we'll get at this
divided up fraction number cleaner
concept okay so for starters what you're
used to seeing as a fraction is what we
call a common fraction common fraction
okay
so I'll give an example for all of this
okay
what's in this common fraction you can
think of uh-huh
and we write it like this right 1 over 2
is how we might read it okay now these
different parts of a fracture they all
have names do we know some of the names
there are 3 parts 1 2 3 is they don't
know what they're called yep
which one's the denominator it's the -
isn't it so that's the D norm being a
tough right okay yes good this guy up
here the 1 is the numerator okay but
boyish bonus points who knows what that
thing in the middle is cool and it's it
is a lie but it's not cold alive I'll
give you tip it starts with the letter P
look V anyone think they know it okay
it's a read it's a lead I think I've
heard it's only vegetarian it's called a
vinculum okay it was almost okay alright
so they go there are the pieces of a
common fraction but there's different
kinds of types of fractions right um for
instance when the denominator is bigger
than the numerator like if you had say 3
over 2 okay we call that something else
this one is a proper fraction
because the numerator is smaller does
anyone know what it's called can anyone
guess what it's called when the
numerators bigger yep I'm gonna improper
good so an improper fraction the example
I just gave you was three over two but
anywhere where the numerator is bigger
than the denominator 7 over 4 8 over 5
and on run run that's an improper
fraction ok one more kind of fraction
though we're interesting is sort on a
fraction they don't know what it's
called yep
mixing ratios now I'm running out space
here so I don't like you and this was
sort of one two three a mixed numeral so
you have a look at this improper
fraction right and the funny thing about
it like the idea of a fraction is that
it's a part right it's not the whole
thing it's just you know one divided
section of it right but here there's
actually an integer hiding in there
isn't there if I can separate it out you
can see there's a 1 hiding in there
right because I can write 3 over 2 right
I can write that separately as 2 plus 1
over 2 right and one of the things we
know about fractions is that you can
separate out that numerator can't do it
with the dumb denominator I want you
have to think about wine but you can
separate out the numerator like so okay
this guy down divider components a bit
creeping like that but anyway now 2 over
2 as you said that's an integer that's 1
and then we just write that a half there
1 and a half okay by the way what I just
did there is how you convert from an
improper fraction to a mixed new rule
how would you go about the other way if
I had if I gave you one and a half you
know what it's equal to but how do you
get that mmm
yeah
ok so I've got 1/2 right so I say 2
times 1 and then what do I do with that
that's to know like yeah I add it don't
I I add it to this so it goes around
like that ok so that's how you get to
the 2 plus 1 over 2 which is exactly
what we had over here times 3 over 2
let's see if you really get it what it
was they have 1 again before I said on
let's try a bigger one
let's try 18 over 5 that's also in
improper fraction how can we convert
this into a mixed numeral yeah totally
don't know we need to know how to do
things right like a little loan ok what
should I write next
ok what is the remainder by the way it's
also 3 isn't it okay fine good ok yeah
all right excellent now I'm just going
to I need a little bit more space these
were the three types of fractions ok now
with this same idea of divided up stuff
fractions have some cousins ok you don't
have to call this subheading cousins of
fractions but the other things that are
very similar to fractions are
percentages right and we're going to
have a look at these as well so things
like our 50% 50% per set that's
important versus that's where the word
percentage comes from I need is what
does it mean it means out of 100 like
sent as a century or Centurion right so
it means like out of
hundred okay and lastly percentages
fractions and the last one we look at is
the decimal okay so for example can
someone tell me what is the decimal of a
half or 50% they're all the same how
would I write it James yeah good 0.50
does matter right
so when you say 0.5 you like okay I know
what that is but the zeros important
happening